- So! Zwei Schnitzel à la Tarek.
- Dankeschön, Max. Sehr nett.
- Lasst es euch schmecken.
- Guten Appetit, Nico.
- Guten Appetit, Inge.
- Ich hab' gehört, du spielst Fußball?
- Ja, stimmt.
- Bald spielst du mit uns zusammen
Fußball. Nächste Woche!
- Was machst du denn noch in deiner
Freizeit? Joggst du gerne?
- Nein, ich jogge nicht gern.
Aber ich schwimme manchmal. Ich höre
viel Musik und fahre viel Fahrrad.
Aber am liebsten mache ich …
das da ...
- Angeln? Du angelst gern?
- Angeln, ja. Ich gehe gern angeln.
- Na, das ist ja was! Ihr beiden
angelt doch auch!
- Wenn wir Zeit haben.
Wir gehen auch gern ins Theater und
ins Kino, aber am liebsten angeln wir.
Komm mal her, ich zeige dir
mal ein paar Fotos.
Ich suche die Fotos von letztem Jahr.
Das war …
verrückt.
Erst hab' ich gar nichts gefangen,
wollte schon aufgeben,
und dann
zieht es und heraus
kam ein riesiger Hecht.
Irgendwo müssen die Fotos sein …
- Das ist Yara!
- Du kennst Yara?
- Das ist meine Tante!
- Yara ist deine Tante?
- Ja, meine Tante.